this is interesting to me we asked
ronnie which staff couple would he most
want to see have sex
oh will and his wife jason and his wife
are john hein and his wife
and ronnie had an interesting answer to
this do you remember your answer ron
oh i said john hine red tell him why
i love john okay right but i i just
i just love to see how it works
because debbie is so petite and
beautiful and
cute and and and small and john's
this big hunk you know what i'm saying i
just
it's like king kong and fay ray right
yeah right
yeah you're like hey king kong's in love
with fay ray but how's king kong gonna
[ __ ] faye ray when he gets down to it
do you think like he'd crush her here's
how i picture it
this poor little skinny debbie laying
there
nicely on her back right here's john
but he's not putting all his weight on
it like he's got his hands
on the mattress and he's not pulling
pulling you know
he's got he's got he's doing it but he's
not
laying on her you know what i'm saying
right that's how i picture it
yeah it's like a blue whale on a mouse
[Laughter]
well john do you want to verify any of
that
[Laughter]
i'm still reeling from the king kong
fay-ray comment
i'm just trying to say what ronnie's
saying in a different way
it's not my interpretation i understand
uh no it's just
to work it out over the last uh couple
decades being together
i mean if you were a little classier
ronnie you instead of being insulting
you say it's like beauty and the beast
that's right i wasn't insulting i wasn't
being insulting
i'd just love to see how it worked out
that's all and john can hold her
in the center of his hand yes that's
kong true climbing up the empire state
building
yeah i guess i i should be honored in in
some way right i mean
no he wants to see it because he doesn't
think it's possible for you to
mount your
well he's banging her on the top of the
empire state building he's also swiping
at airplanes
you